[Music]
my song
okay
he hasn't taken his meds
and tonight
okay
uh and when you say he threatened you uh
what exactly did he
i'll say over to two if you wanna
monitor one
um
i'm sorry what did you say exactly he
said sir i remember i i don't remember
what he said but he was kind of waving
the knives at you yeah
okay
and you obviously
are concerned that he's gonna attack you
with the knives yes okay
uh did he make any comments verbally
besides just
his
his like body language well
he doesn't make any sense when he's
off his meds
so i don't i don't
okay how old is he
he's 35
uh if we knock on the door do you
anticipate him
uh
be becoming violent with us or anything
i don't know he's never been off his
meds for three days okay
what would you like for us to do
take him to the puff
yeah
all right well we'll talk to him and
we'll see if we can
talk some sense into him all right and
maybe get him to come with us and
uh if not maybe we'll put him on a
on a psych evaluation hold if he can
meet the criteria yeah
oh he'll meet the card too
okay well we'll we'll make that uh
determination right now is it
no
very good all right well i'll tell you
what why don't you just hang out in your
car
so that you don't you know agitate him
or something if he sees you
and we'll just go knock on the door
we'll try to chat with them all right
we go down the hall
we're probably just going to hang out
outside instead of going in there we
don't want to
we don't want to agitate him you know
what i mean
so what are you going to do we're gonna
knock on the door and talk to him first
instead of just wandering in there and
we don't want to surprise him you know
uh the door he's not gonna hear
he won't hear the door
yeah
yeah would you mind maybe calling him
for us and i can just talk to him i have
a phone he's got myself oh you don't
have a phone okay well we'll tell you
what we'll try knocking on the door
first and then if that doesn't work then
we'll give them a call okay okay you
don't think you'll hear us at the front
door knocking on the door no
okay well we'll give it a try just in
case
hey dylan
um
dylan you in your buddy
it's gonna peek right here
all right
so
dylan buddy you in here
i hear your voice are you there dylan
dylan
can you hear me
hey
buddy i can barely hear you to be honest
you don't need to open the door but if
you could just come a little bit closer
to the door so i could hear you
[Music]
hey dylan i can barely hear you buddy
would it be okay if i came around back
to the window
okay if you would if you'd mind it would
be better for me if you could just come
a little bit closer to the door you
don't have to open it
is that all right
can you come
can you come a little bit closer to the
door so i can hear you
the screen
so it sounds like everything is kind of
over this phone situation is that right
[Music]
hey dylan can i ask you a question buddy
you're uh your mom
hey dylan so kimberly mentioned
something about some knives
do you have those knives with you now
would you mind putting those down for me
but hey i'm not we're not saying you did
anything wrong buddy it's just hard for
me to hear you over all these fireworks
hey dylan would you do me a favor
would you do me a favor would you put
those knives down and come out here and
talk to me
i did but it would be easier for me to
hear you if you were out here
but i need you to do me a favor okay
please please please put those knives
down okay buddy
okay very good i'm gonna let you come
out here and sit on the couch all right
yep we're ready for you to open the door
buddy
hey dylan are you ready
okay
are you gonna come out here and sit on
the couch
yes sir i will sit on the couch if
you'll sit on the couch
can i ask you a question real quick
buddy you don't have those knives on you
right no i don't will you just turn your
pockets inside out for me and show me
yeah is that okay hey but i got another
thing
to tell you though
i'm in an emergency
yes sir did you hear anything
i heard a little bit but it's so loud
outside it's hard for me to hear huh
what's what's wrong all i know is they
have it's also a hospital you know they
have crazy things to say about can't
believe me that's not uh well since
that's one of their concern but it kind
of looks like he came over to like try
to put me under around but then i didn't
do anything no we just delete the house
people are just calling verbal arguments
everything's there hey one more thing oh
also they said chasey with the motor gun
don't want to leave this hospital yeah
it's in the backyard but then you go
first tell me what's going on dylan can
i just ask one more question would you
mind just kind of would you just show me
you don't have any other knives or
nothing on you just because your dad
said something about knives so we're all
freaked out about it honestly we're all
nervous about them so i hope you can
understand
it's a little bit too long all right
would you for waiting to partner myself
with friends come on would you like to
sit down and talk i don't want to walk
past in case it sounds like something
where it's aggressive towards me i'm not
going to are you worried about the door
yeah you want me to close the door would
it feel would it make you feel better if
i close that door yeah i put another
thing buddy we'll close the door right
now
my partner's closing i'm supposed to
jack off so they don't have a problem
straight so remember the first time you
came in here do you remember that had to
see if you would get it straight yeah
well see that's what it is
if you can wait till we leave to start
doing that i would super appreciate it
all right
buddy do you want to sit down right here
at the table with me
um george and abraham is my spouse look
come on let's go sit down here
uh do you mind if i sit at the table
with you yeah he's supposed to be a
phone there you go buddy you sit right
there would you like me to sit down as
well or would you rather i stand yeah
sit down okay cool man they're supposed
to go four and a half years he invites
everything this is compressed all this
kennedy side living with me and i'll
tell you what whatever i'm commissioning
cover up fuck it hey can we can't wait
let's sit down here buddy yeah that's it
let's sit back
it's good how long has it been i'm not
taking over dude here's the thing ellen
speaking towards your dad that's all i
know hey so what was the deal with the
knives man what what was going on with
uh kimberly i was knocking on my door
non-stop i don't think that's him he
started banging on the door mm-hmm yeah
don't be honest
i could tell you
[Music]
they don't want to see you they said you
counted the house we're proceeding no
one got hurt watching case you got the
bike so you gotta get here i see that's
what the other guy said it's true
hey dylan do you have any kind of like
uh dance i got to say that
do you take any kind of like medication
or anything like that no i'm not but the
guy was given to me they know that too
what kind of medication do you take
no i
before you graduated what kind of
medication were you taking
uh
what kind of meditation yeah anything
well went to the zero office mine's
serious and they haven't opened that
because they're like other
take your medicine first
yeah yeah what kind of uh i'm a man too
i've been adopted to the world right
when you were talking to the doctors a
lot dylan yeah were they telling you
that you had
anything crazy like that yeah they're
talking about all the time but i passed
the test
dylan do you feel um
are you hearing like voices or anything
right now what are you hearing any
voices or anything right now no i'm not
i don't know it's kind of just like he
was going to attack me i got scared each
other
though do you have soft control shit
yeah and pick up all the confessions on
that phone i need something like
like what being the other one to use the
phone and work with him for some reason
he tripped out last night too he just
came to the kitchen said he was mad got
that up and he just believe what if
there was anything kimberly i'm sorry uh
dylan do you feel like calling me talk
to him yeah i mean do you feel like
hurting anybody else tonight man uh-huh
no not at all also i've been to the good
checks and even cars
you got a clock an iron you know me
swear to god
every time you guys come around
this guy acts weird and i've been having
after like thousands of times it's my
first time here mm-hmm and then it's
supposed to be around because those
people you're with
all right um kimberly i'll tell you what
buddy i'm sorry dylan i'm sorry man i'll
get my name's all mixed up uh if you
wouldn't mind i'm gonna step outside
real quick i'm gonna talk to kimberly
one more time they know all the weird
stuff yeah yeah yeah would you mind just
hanging out here and waiting for me man
yeah and you can talk to my partner he's
a good conversationalist man he'll tell
you all about
chickens or irrigating you know water
farm-related things if you're interested
in that type of stuff all right remember
i'm king david too would it be okay if i
want to walk around here
i'm just gonna walk right right around
behind you all right
so what's going on
[Music]
okay
um so we're in there we're talking to
dylan he's being pretty cool with us
uh obviously it does seem like he's kind
of off his medication um is this just
the neighbor or
yep yeah okay cool make sure there's the
okay yeah
yeah
um
so he's saying basically that it was
it was kind of a misunderstanding but
with you and the knife thing i just
wanted to kind of shore up some stuff
with you
um
just to
these confirm are crazy man
the way that he's acting now
is not typical behavior for him
is that right yes
so he's normally
pretty normal when you talk to him
well
but right now like he can't really even
have a conversation no
that's not that's not usual for him
right no that is it is usual
uh as far as the nice thing went can you
just walk me through it one more time
the reason i'm just clarifying this
stuff
is we don't want to just snatch people
up and drag them off to the hospital
against their will of willy-nilly you
know what i mean i understand okay
so can you just kind of go clarify the
knife stuff with him over there buddy
you can hang out it's up to it's up to
kimberly honestly with yeah
over there
no no hang out all right
um
yeah as much detail as possible is great
for us
okay
i was trying to get myself
okay because he took your cell phone
right yes okay
and i told him he lost his i told him
that i would get another cell phone
before tomorrow
but
he says he needs a cell phone for his
protection
okay
so
i knocked on his door and went to the
back knocked on his window
and he got really upset
okay
[Music]
okay and what did you do when he did
that
i did i did whatever
but you got to use you got to give me
some descriptive words here just tell me
kind of play by play what happened so he
comes into the room he's pointing the
knives at you waving him around in kind
of a threatening manner yes and then
what did you do after that
i do what
uh ever
i can do to calm him down
and what did you do at that time to calm
him down
i
turned dog step
you turned off the stereo okay because
that's what he wanted you to do
yeah okay
uh and that behavior for him is unusual
right
yes okay
um all right we'll tell you what we're
gonna take him to the hospital and we're
gonna get him checked out again
okay okay
they aim we're going to call the
ambulance and see if they can take him
okay so they should be here
before too long right so if you just
want to hang out
everything's okay
can you start a market right now
yes
all right buddy i'm back
what's up dude i don't need to go to the
hospital do you want to stand me down
and take right
i'm sorry could you repeat that one more
time i said i i said you don't have to
take him to the hospital i've been
talking to him talk to him
yeah it's
live here it's a hospital dude
oh
[Music]
dylan how would you feel about going and
uh talking to the doctor man i don't
think you're at the doctor i'm just a
cop i don't know a lot of stuff about
medical stuff i'm not supposed my
i
would you be cool going to the hospital
and talking to a doctor and getting some
new medication long time to smoke i feel
like i need to talk to you more after i
get some water buddy where's the
cigarette i'll grab it for you right now
it's in my room do you want to grab it
for you yeah yeah tell me where it's at
technology
where's that it's on my next hand
buddy my partner grabber right now i'll
smoke
we'll smoke a couple cigarettes together
right now yeah if he was trying to get
safe here's what we did dude we got the
president monster van i want
the neighbors love morel they gotta move
next they're gonna like shit them in the
face because they're not supposed to see
cops okay not dangerous that's their job
she's not gonna do a main paper saying
you can't go over every second kimberly
don't leave this for a moment buddy i
got good news for you
spark it up buddy
that's all you man
cool i got a bunch of stuff too you got
keys
right now yeah what are these man are
these clothes
that's how my dream okay
somebody creature
this
is it significant i'm a local by the way
that's why i said i thought you learned
a lot of miles mm-hmm
boys is good girls i don't really mean
that but
yeah she can't be here too there's a
girl but i need someone to like
say i live in that room with
non-eruptions but the way it's been on
my doorstep
right
so what do we do we do the handlebar
fingerprint
i already did i wrote the girlfriend
guys
since they're over there
they don't wanna know they told me he
said this happened
like tell can't believe they called
something he doesn't know how to house
the different side
golfers sure
right his life like that there we
already did that he gave me this plan
buddy is so busy tonight man it's off
the hook there's fireworks and all sorts
of craziness going on david yeah
are you intellectually smart not yet
this is good
i'm supposed to go to work i did are you
on the midsize
what's there what do you do there
oh there
you have a fabricated on the house
whatever
i kind of programmed to start like this
is the fermented healthy place where we
could see we're studying
it's pretty cool so what are you guys
doing uh we're police officers we work
from the city of modesto's police
officers
so how do you become a police officer
piper john yeah you just gotta apply man
i'm new here pretty much as long as you
have a pulse man you're good to go
they'll take anybody
is be careful but you're dropping a
little bit of ash on your sweatpants i
don't want you to burn a hole in your uh
in your trousers there man sure i'm just
calling it my alcohol i'm gonna push
that cs
for sure man yeah all right
so the grinding ain't talking to the
player
giant kid
the medicine does work all i know is
kevin's supposed to be here with that i
don't know his problem is serious what
did he do the nine things ain't my fault
what did happen when he called you with
his because he probably didn't see the
knife thing he painted his phone saying
dylan's okay too but here's what he did
he called you guys i don't know why
you're here
but we just want to make sure everyone's
all cool man but don't think that like i
don't trust you or something
dylan you seem like the type of guy that
would play an instrument
do you play music at all
no not really whatever i did probably
never do it again what do you do for fun
man you got any hobbies everything you
just play on your phone there it is
huh i finished reading
i've been telling my partner you should
learn man it'd be a great form it's a
good way to pass the time
doctors you could talk to her about
craving and
i guess what i'm talking about
conversation
pretty funny
that's all i was trying to do the first
time masturbating
[Music]
there's only one thing they said
anything bad happens save the house
he's
i'm like golf drugs they're so so weird
i'm kind of all right
like we smell cold
i thought i was going to bite to
remember to like be my friend they don't
have to do that though but then did you
have that last time
um
uh well dylan i have an idea buddy
and you can tell me which thing
but i only put the livestream
oh yeah
but what else
once you're done pulling off that thing
that's all around again how would you
feel about uh going and talking to the
doctor
the thing is doctor parents by giving
respect we don't need to talk to the
doctor because unless you got something
in front of you yeah i don't want
nothing
well here's the deal buddy with uh with
the stuff here with the stuff that
kimberly said
your dad or your mom uh what the stuff
that kimberly said
um
we gotta have you talk to a doctor okay
and they just gotta give you the all
clear
all right so here's the deal
oh i gotta say so how do you wear it
give me the deal i'm gonna give you a
deal right now buddy if there's a couple
like little personal items that you want
to bring along with you well i don't
like you
if there's anything like you can't bring
cigarettes and stuff because they won't
let you really smoke there but if you
want to bring like a book or maybe like
an ipad or something i don't have you
got anything like that you can is that
something that you're interested in i
talk camera everyday
yeah no
[Music]
arrested i promise you okay i promise
you're not being arrested okay so i can
stay tight you can't stay you can't stay
but you're not being arrested
you're not going to go to jail you're
just going to go to the hospital they're
just going to talk to you okay
do you want to have fun
do i want to work in my life
[Music]
oh so the ambulance is going to be here
in about uh that's why
they're probably going to be about 15
minutes okay
so what i think we should do in the
meantime
i want to go out to the street
and i want us to all sit in my car
and i want to scratch out a piece of
paperwork that we can give to the
ambulance when they get here okay does
that sound cool okay can we do that
yeah they i think they have
chiropractors
is that cool with you buddy
so as soon as you're done with that man
it looks like you're about done
you want to come out to my car with me
would that be cool
uh no
i know you want to leave buddy but
unfortunately it's not it's not uh
for discussion you know what i mean
hey
it's actually a legal question
it's illegal for what for them to put on
arrest by the military you gotta hear a
confession before i go in the car
and then i say like i don't wanna die
but come back home i don't know whatever
yeah and then i don't like to call him
to get out and walk back time i just did
the swear to god okay imagine that's
where man's coming from saying he wanted
to get everything again he's here with
everything too yeah
for sure
yeah anything really yeah and they don't
want to think they're either going to
talk to them already
so they could do their job or whatever
i'm really cool too don't sign do you
know what's up
right
just hang tight for one second bro
before you burn it up but thank you for
asking i appreciate that
yeah well we'll have one outside buddy i
just don't want it to delay us too much
all right mister i'll tell you what i'll
make you a deal
we can have another cigarette but let's
have it outside by the car okay does
that sound cool really 100
you want to do that
grab your stuff and let's start heading
outside
yeah
you know what buddy
i don't know
it's not illegal trust me it's not bro
judge me do you want to grab that phone
yeah actually yeah grab the phone and
bring it outside
it has to be okay
okay let's go right i hear you follow my
partner onto the road ashley i don't
want to get arrested buddy we're not
going to arrest you i promise you oh so
i'm just going to go out there and talk
we're just going to go out to the car
and we're just going to talk to the
doctor okay but i'm not under arrest
anything right but hey you didn't do
anything wrong
you fucking say their neighbor
military's not pleased
nobody shot no neighbors man don't worry
how about you
guess i don't know anymore because
that's on the house do you want to sell
my chair
i don't want to sit anymore buddy we're
going to go out to the car well why
would i go out to the car it's not
saying it's no insane to go put yourself
on a rescue and do anything you know
right for sure i'll get you all right
hey
this time monday's there also proper if
you go ladies and gents she has regards
she has gold rings bugs whatever you
need you know what i mean i got you go
to the office well say anything you want
to know good anymore no problems 49
hours to leave you know what i mean is
that okay dylan would it be okay if you
walk outside for me would that be cool
man i'd super appreciate it come on hold
on just go involve him follow him buddy
okay so i'm going to talk to you at the
car but i'm not going in that's what i
requested because i'm scared of you guys
there's no need to be scared
i promise you
you're not you're not going to get in
any kind of trouble okay go ahead i'm
not going to i don't want to be close to
you when you walk by because i can tell
you a little can i touch your
protection
can you what can i touch your arm safety
protection 100 you want to touch it yeah
touch it scout's on her buddy
hey
hey i'm a couple you're looking out
there so yeah
call me top they're supposed to live
here too yeah after coming so now that
we have done that that's all can we go
outside
yeah go ahead do you join us here you
follow me you promise uh yeah i'll
probably get a promise you promise god's
honor all right here we go
hey thank you
yeah
also
if that works with you i don't know
about that yeah camera's drinking this
guy yeah i'm not drinking dude
cool yeah call it close doctors have
them come over here too
you want to you want us to bring the car
right here
would you feel better if the car was
right here yeah i would be cool i'm
supposed to operational all right mike's
gonna grab the car he's gonna bring it
right here all right yeah
yeah bring your car up
why i didn't hurt nobody gotta scare
someone
you see it sorry guys
okay so we're here just pretending
you're talking to me waiting for the
doctor to come or whatever like he's got
furniture
i just woke up
i got final fantasy i got you're
supposed to say give me a leader in
charge
they're not correct
all i know is there's supposed to be a
door shut four and a half years i'm so
open so disrespected by fucking kimberly
saying he's not supposed to jeopardize
us at the hospital while i take my
medicine and then say don't go away but
what do you call the police for i don't
know i just woke up
yeah i don't know nothing about that man
that's crazy
see i'm addicted to the medicine
talk to him he said he's the judge
please go next door did you hear michael
looks like a kidnapper what do you think
you're talking about like put my hand
around your shoulder
it's not gay i guess you can't say it
later and it'll play it all this
see that i haven't changed to moderation
i want you to let it go
make sure that there are people
whatever come here report next door or
go off they're trying to do it it says
check your phone you just lost your job
i swear to god you lost your job look at
it check your machine send it down up to
nothing else
is his dad here well listen
this is all kind of old
george's not safe enough like what am i
keep going
all right dylan check it out man tell me
what's going on
would you feel comfortable standing next
to my car while we while we chat now
that you pretend to get arrested like
you did something wrong on a medicine
because you can't afford it
all right hey would it be all right
if you continue smoking and you just
hang out here with my partner mike and
i'm just going to go do paperwork in the
car okay all right is that cool yeah and
i'll tell you more later i'm going to be
right there you got any problems if mike
starts
you know
talking your ear off or something you
just holler at me and i'll tell them to
shut up okay all right all right all
right i gotta go
did you want me to get mine if you
believe jacket i'm supposed to be
wearing it and then i'm talking about
cell phone we're missing two electrical
devices and just woke up i can't find
mine here
so he started questioning like he said
like
i'm gonna call the place now like she
wants to grab my eyes but she's like put
in your room on the wall and then say
look at it and then say when if they get
here
trust me dude i'm not crazy i don't know
you could be gay
i know but you know the end the the
office is what you're standing at looks
weird this says that this is uh
come out one of the neighbors and stand
down with them because i'm not gonna
make any sense you're gonna have a
question i would have to say i can't
remember
i'm only a couple seconds old and get
one after they know their turn
right go with gay she don't like that
don't tell my name though
what is your name
i learned in school when i was trying to
take the test i said i couldn't be
myself i said i was talking to him good
job
so if you don't got a name you know i've
got a car
this is here helicopter something
texas toilet paper component tell them
all right so your partner says talk you
should talk to your partner like he's
there and talk to the hospital people
here the whole thing is someone's out to
get him too someone's here it's the same
problem
it looks very strange so since i
reported sansan i love you
i love myself is it okay to fight wait
for the doctor when you go first or then
you want me to go back to my house and
get a slave i don't want you to go back
in your house just yet i just want you
to
the ambulance is gonna get here
and then they're gonna they're gonna
check you out real quick you'll hop in
the ambulance they'll take you to go
talk to the doctor real quick i gotta
lay down also i'm very strong i got a
201 i got a line two nominations i want
the barracks i've never ever seen the
place before this hasn't been on any
crossing i'm only aiming on earth
yeah is the part here she's gotta talk
to work for george after
fuck it do it his way i don't think
she's gonna work with her i think she's
gonna help me considering hero
make sure kennedy's safe so he can't
believe they never come back i swear to
god like where's the victim
you know what i did to get a chance to
look around a little bit but i'm going
to take a rain check on the tour okay
all right we'll do that later
all right we'll do that next time
thank you though buddy i appreciate that
that's very kind of your dog
are you kidding me he does yeah what are
you thinking that's yours her okay
[Music]
walk me out the house for one second i
don't even know it's like not even there
i just wanted to question the response
you need to be interested i was
concerned about just in case
we don't have to we don't have to talk
about that really right now okay i'll
tell you what man let's go mike hey
kimberly could you take care of the
police officer stand down i guess i'll
just pretend i'm here i'll pretend i'm
not here
i don't wanna you threaten me
no it wasn't like that actually cheers
put up against the side she says
let's just touch or watch it's going on
in case like they're crazy enough and
then someone's here
that's what you said that's all
by the way
if you don't do that well you got life
you need to go there even if he leaves
you what i mean even if you drive away
she's gonna go
statement response chase him with the
gun okay so do you have for proof and
then everyone knows
the jokes
is there a different form that i don't
know about the old ones
oh the old one
yeah oh let me look at my back i might
have one
anyone just keep an eye on him
he's having a hard time
[Applause]
um
[Music]
dylan dylan come on over here burner
all right i'm gonna go keep an eye on
him
and just holler at me when colin's here
oh
but you're not going to go under arrest
don't worry about that i promise you
yeah okay you're gonna be under arrest
all right yeah i promise you thank you
very much sure
uh regards for yours
is trimble okay now he looks normal
again since i'm mental it's legal
i didn't do anything holy crap that's a
lot of pills man those are all the ones
you're supposed to take today uh-huh
okay
thank you lord
i always want to stand up for myself
i want to say i saved my life because i
make mine
boys make me excited
camera's kind of studying now
it might hear like girls yeah that's
kind of all you know until you say you
jack off to say get
here's what i want you to do i want you
to take doane's word for it he's here
with police they always came by but it
wasn't to put under the rest to make
sure we're comfortable here
can you talk to kimberly fine and just
ask me what you've been saying because
i will talk to him all right can you do
me a favor yes sir can we come out of
this room can we go to this room
yeah yeah i'll tell you what no actually
it's safe
i don't like this room here's why okay
there you got all sorts of knives and
other peripherals line right here
it's making me a little bit nervous to
be honest with you it's scary too it's
kind of scaring me a little bit huh if
we could go out here and make me feel
way better to be honest with you buddy
i don't think i have to go because i'm
innocent and then that's a little bit
kidnapped someone why would you kid that
buddy we're not gonna go anywhere i'm
just saying can we just walk out of this
room can we go back in the living room
is that okay no i don't think i'll allow
that
dylan please buddy you've been so you've
been so cool just like come on come on i
didn't i'll let you touch my badge man
you remember that i like your badge yeah
yeah yeah that was the spirit of honor
you said it yourself oh they just
cracked my back on their masking man hey
talk to kimberly because he's the judge
to stand down if not he's under arrest
that's what i'm supposed to say don't
like us and i love you
that's all for for sure
all right
so can we go out back and live in our
man you can but i'm gonna go sleep
because i never called you in a random
okay but everything's cooler
and i'll pay off this for 9 percent
mm-hmm as much as any of the thoughts
get
i'll get more for you okay yeah don't
listen buddy that's kind of how doing
time don't go nowhere though okay
he tried
okay hey can we go outside and talk to
the ambulance bro yeah is that cool you
can you can go back to can you come with
me i'm not supposed to yes
can you stand down and tell him what the
richter skull is
rick just got roshio supposed to say i
will get the neighbor to come over then
he's going to go to the ambulance
the ambulance is already here
you broke the law he goes to jail i'm in
court dude
i know but i'm gonna have to talk to you
guys after that's why if it's serious
shit it is but if it's just like nothing
to pull around like if not it's right
because being themselves
yeah all right come on come on everybody
let's go outside can we talk to you no
hey relax
that was a gunshot dylan